here is trevor bauer he's given up one
or fewer runs in seven of his nine
starts this year this guy has been
amazing all year here's tim anderson
as a swing and a miss on a pitch in the
dirt and that was nasty tim anderson
chases it and strikes out so a good
start for bauer yes monty grandahl
stands in
tough swing right there and he strikes
out that's back-to-back case for bauer
two down on the first inning that was a
perfect backdoor slider and grundahl
emergency hack no chance i'll bring up
jose abreu
did he go yes he did
mike esterbrook said he offered he goes
around and how about bauer he strikes
out the side in the first and in the
return after some back spasms uh for
dallas kykel out there for his tenth
start aquino leading it off here for the
reds
that is strike three picks up the
outside corner and kykel may have gotten
the call there but there's al number one
of this bottom of the first inning so
all of a sudden he got two on here with
one away and here's a eugenio suarez
that is strike three
second strikeout for kykel two down here
in the first inning so two down first
and second brings up tyler stevenson
that is in there for strike three just
like bauer kykel strikes out the side
here in the first it'll be mustache
senzelle and garcia featured here for
cincinnati
and a curveball gets him looking strike
three called and that's four strikeouts
now for dallas kykel one away in the
second no score bases loaded for the
reds stood out here in the inning and
castiano should head 2-0
lifts this one in the air to center
field playable for luis robert who comes
in now he goes back bit of an adventure
but he hauls it in
one out one on and tim anderson standing
in
little number back to the mound and
bauer will go to first base to get the
out madrigal moves on to third base
popped up high into the air
a routine pop-up for suarez at third and
madrigal will be stranded at the same
base reds have runners at first and
second base to begin the third so here's
stevenson
out of strike three grabs the inside
corner as stevenson strikes out and
kykel needed that as he picks up his
fifth case second time stevenson's down
by way of the k on the exact same pitch
twice second and third two down nick
senzell
this one is in the air to right fielded
dave mazzara is back with room to make
the catch shy of the track to end the
inning two on two down and luis robert
coming up
definitely goes that time and strikes
out of the slider bauer has his fourth
strike out of the night garcia leading
it off near the bottom of the fourth
inning and a swing and a miss as garcia
strikes out strikeout number six for
kykel six strikeouts five fly outs
nothing on the ground and that's gonna
be a strikeout seven strikeouts for
dallas kykel and he goes one two three
through the cincinnati reds here in the
fourth defending without a score and the
white sox coming to bat no mar mazzara
hasn't hit a home run yet and he
struggled against off speed and pitchers
have kind of figured that out drives
this one to deep right field and that
ball is gone a home run nomar mazzara
hits his first in a white sox uniform
and it's one to nothing chicago and it
puts the white sox on top one nothing
one out and the top of the order tim
anderson
this one is in the air
to deep center field since ella's back
he is not going to get this one it's
gone second home run given up by bauer
in this inning tim anderson connects on
his ninth i make sure i tell him to put
that on his youtube channel too blog
about that then the white sox take a
two-nothing lead just four innings for
dallas kykel he does not come out for
the fifth doesn't allow a run through
his four innings of work and they turn
the baseball over to matt foster good
news for cincinnati kykel's out of this
game
and going around very defensively there
is vato he strikes out two down on the
fifth that there is an emergency hack
robert leads it off here in the seventh
inning
a little check swing and diving his
power he'll get up and throw him out
robert retired for the first down of the
seventh inning like a cat out there
trevor bauer
who says pitchers aren't athletes dawn
and he's gone at least six innings and
all but one start
that was the season high seven and two
thirds as he strikes out bizarre this
time it picks up his fifth k two down
good pitch here by bauer right at the
bottom of the zone casale just hugs it
up just a little bit to get strike three
power has battled all night and has
worked here into the seventh inning has
two outs he's retired seven in a row
swings with the o2 and up to get it is
power he crawls down the mound and then
fires to first base for the nice play by
trevor bauer three up three down in the
seventh robert stevenson checks into the
game for the reds he's in here to hold
him down the white sox down and try to
give the reds an off a chance on offense
with six outs to go
this one is set to deep right center
field back
at the wall it is gone a home run so tim
anderson has done it again his second
home run of the game
his tenth of the year and it puts the
white sox on top three to nothing osmani
grandahl
this one is driven a deep right field
castellano's back and that ball is gone
so back to back go the white sox in the
eighth inning
they have connected on four home runs
and they lead at four to nothing all
solo shots as the white sox go back to
back in the eighth off robert stephenson
and another absolute blast pitch again
you do this against these white sox you
don't get a lot of them back red sox
doing it all on solo home runs
this one is driven out towards deep left
field off the bat of abreu
they go back to back to back
the white sox in the eighth inning take
a five-nothing lead anderson grandahl
and abreu go back to back to back
we are seeing the white sox what they do
best that is hit long long home runs two
on with one away and that'll bring up
winker
breaking ball is grounded to second base
it is anderson who gets the out there
onto first out there the double play and
it is the double play that will end this
ball game nicely done by anderson
applied the tag
uh galvez first and then turns it into a
dp that wraps it up and it is indeed a
shutout for the white sox an impressive
offensive attack with the five home runs
aj for the white sox